technische probleme mit der gestern
gestartet mars-mission was ist mit der
atlas -rakete los es ist der technisch
anspruchsvollste mars-rover der jemals
von menschenhand entwickelt wurde
am donnerstagmorgen ist per se behrens
in richtung mars gestartet und jetzt ist
die rakete in einer art stand by modus
gegangen wird die nasa das problem lösen
und wird der rover auch nach leben auf
dem mars suchen können klicks zum 20
juli gibt's drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocken nur so verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt es eben ist auch
auf die ohren der link zum podcast ist
hier und ami und unten in der video
beschreibung zu spotify und apple
podcast insgesamt acht jahre lang haben
die forschungsteams der nasa an dem
insgesamt 2,2 milliarden euro teuren
mars rover gearbeitet sein name ist
hoffentlich programm denn person wir uns
bedeutet übersetzt so viel wie
durchhaltevermögen kleine anekdote am
rande diesen namen hatte ein
siebtklässler aus dem us-bundesstaat
virginia der nasa vorgeschlagen der
arbeitstitel des projektes war lange
zeit maß 2020 am frühen donnerstagmorgen
war die atlas 5 rakete von cape
canaveral in florida gestartet das ganze
verlief zunächst planmäßig dazu der nasa
chef jim briten stein mit dem start von
passagieren beginnen wir eine weitere
historische erkundungsmission wir freuen
uns auf eine herausragende
wissenschaftler siemens wird nicht nur
proben zur erde bringen sondern auch den
weg für zukünftige bemannte mission zum
roten planeten ebenen
dann aber musste die nasa technische
schwierigkeiten melden demnach hatte die
trägerrakete in einen sicherheitsmodus
umgeschaltet das kann man sich ein wenig
so vorstellen wie den winterschlaf bei
tieren in diesem abgesicherten modus
stellt die trägerrakete bis auf die
notwendigen systeme alle funktionen ab
nach vermutungen der nasa fachleute
könnten diese probleme darauf begründet
sein dass ein teil des raumschiffs im
erdschatten zu kalt geworden ist kein
grund zur beunruhigung aber heißt es
nach offiziellen angaben auf twitter
hieß es vom stellvertretende
missionsleiter mad world space kreft
israeli design to operate in space where
it happy ist frei übersetzt so viel wie
da
ein fahrzeug ist wirklich für den
weltraum entwickelt worden dort fühlt
sie sich am wohlsten sobald die
temperaturen wieder normal werte
erreichen wolle man das raumschiff
wieder in den normalen modus zurück
schalten die sei wahrscheinlich bereits
in den kommenden stunden der fall
doch auch anderweitig mussten die nasa
fachleute zittern denn bei dem aufbau
der kommunikationsverbindung zudem
steuerungs zentrum für die marsmission
dem jet propulsion laboratorium kam es
zu kleinen verzögerung das alles wird
derzeit umfassend überprüft von
schwerwiegenden problemen sei aber nicht
auszugeben insgesamt sind es 480
millionen kilometer die person wir uns
zu bewältigen hat wenn der plan aufgeht
soll der mars-rover dann im kommenden
februar 2021 auf dem roten planeten
landen der ausgewählte landeplatz der
zerotracer ein ausgetrockneter see ein
ort der zuvor noch niemals genauer unter
die lupe genommen wurden hier soll der
rover nach lebensform suchen die
möglicherweise auf dem mars existierten
dazu der nasa wissenschafts direkter
thomas zu buchen
der zero krater ist der perfekte ort um
nach zeichen vergangenen lebens zu
suchen
so können wir verstehen wie der mars
einmal war und warum man nun so ist wie
er ist
zunächst soll per sie während also nach
gesteinsproben suchen die im jahr 2031
mit hilfe einer weiteren raumsonde zur
erde zurückgebracht werden sollen ganz
vorne mit dabei
die europäische weltraumagentur esa der
ehemalige chef des nasa mars programm
scott hubbard hatte proben vom roten
planeten mal als zitat heiligen gral der
mars wissenschaften bezeichnet die
fachleute jedenfalls sind sich sicher
dass passivieren uns auf der intensiven
suche nach leben einen großen schritt
nach vorne bringen wird dazu nasa chef
jim prinz sein
wir wissen nicht ob dort leben existiert
hat oder nicht aber wir wissen dass der
mars in seiner geschichte einmal
bewohner waren
doch nicht nur bei der suche nach leben
soll uns provence spektakuläre
erkenntnisse liefern
dazu schreibt die nasa der rover soll
nach spuren von früheren leben suchen
neue technologien für die zukunft
menschliche exploration testen und die
ersten stein proben sammeln die wieder
zur erde zurückgebracht werden sollen
anfang des jahres 2020 hatten die nasa
fachleute seien instrumente im heißen
und
südaustralien getestet und zwar mit
erfolg dafür hatte das australische
forschungsteam nachbauten der
originalinstrumente von provence auf die
spurensuche in einem gebüsch zog in der
nähe von adelaide geschickt dazu die
astrobiologin bonität die gegen dort
eignet sich sehr gut um forschung zu
betreiben wie auf dem mars es ist ein
trockenes staubiges und windiges gebiet
sehr kalt dass eine gute analogien
bietet um wie auf dem mars nach leben zu
suchen
die aufgabe war klar definiert die
instrumente sollten in den felsen die
besten stellen identifizieren die
möglicherweise biomarker organische
komponenten oder fossilien von
mikroorganismen enthalten könnten mit am
start waren ein röntgen instrument eine
kamera mit hoher auflösung in der ferne
und ein spektrometer das bio signaturen
aufspüren soll
um messfehler auszuschließen müssen
verschiedene instrumente eindeutige
hinweise liefern und genau das passierte
die person ihre instrumente konnten über
500 millionen jahre alte spuren des
lebens aufspüren die instrumente haben
damit den test gut bestanden auf dem
mars selbst ist geplant dass der rover
nicht nur gesteinsproben gewinnt die zur
erde gebracht werden sollen auch die
mars oberfläche soll er detailliert
analysieren eines forschungsteam hat
jetzt gerade auch noch einmal bestätigt
dass das angepeilte untersuchungsgebiet
auf dem roten planeten gut gewählt ist
im bereich des zero kraters zeichnen
sich nämlich höchstwahrscheinlich reste
eines einstigen flussdeltas ab und das
ist für die suche nach spuren von leben
natürlich äußerst vielversprechend auch
modellsimulationen machen große hoffnung
denn sie offenbaren dass der fluss im
zero krater mögliche mikrobielle
lebensformen auf der mars oberfläche 1
fort getragen haben könnte und sie sich
somit geschützt unter den sedimenten
abgelagert haben dazu der forscher
mathieu laporte es sollen bei der
mission die ersten proben entstehen die
für untersuchungen vom mars zur erde
gebracht werden das ist sehr aufregend
denn es könnte sich damit die chance
ergeben einblicke in die entstehung von
leben auf einem anderen planeten zu
gewinnen und somit auch die frage was
leben überhaupt ist und jetzt zu den
spektakulären technischen details von
siemens er hat in etwa die größe eines
kleinen autos und ist
rund 1000 kilogramm also eine tonne
schwer er ist der fünfte und bis dann
technisch komplizierteste mars-rover der
usa wenn nicht nur alle negativen
sondern auch positiven erfahrungen die
die nasa in den vorherigen missionen
gesammelt hatte wurden bei der planung
und dem bau von peer sowie events
berücksichtigt denn er verfügt nicht nur
über einen roboterarm und 20 kameras
sondern auch über einen mini
hubschrauber auch deutsche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben zu der herausragenden technik
beigetragen so sind unter anderem thermo
sensoren des leibniz instituts für
photonische technologien in jener mit am
start sie ermöglichen es die
oberflächentemperatur des planeten zu
messen und das ganz ohne berührung neben
dem riesigen technischen aufwand hat der
rover noch andere dinge mit an bord und
zwar drei chips die jeweils etwa so groß
sind wie ein finger darauf enthalten
sind die namen von knapp elf millionen
menschen
dahinter steckt eine kampagne der nasa
mit der bezeichnung send your name
thomas menschen aus der ganzen welt
bekam so die möglichkeit quasi mit an
bord des rovers zum roten planeten zu
reisen wie hier bei pixum haben ja schon
auch mal bei einer anderer mission
mitgemacht falls provence ist
tatsächlich auf dem mars schafft wäre es
der insgesamt fünfte rover den die nasa
zum mars gebracht hat den anfang hatte
es sogar im jahr 1997 gemacht der rund
drei monate daten zur erde schickt dann
kamen die zwillings rover opportunity
und spirit und zwar vor 16 jahren 2004
jahre später aber verlor die nasa den
kontakt zu spirit bedingt durch einen
staubsturm und das gleiche schicksal
erlitt opportunity dann später 2018 der
mars roboter der wohl ganz oben auf der
beliebtheitsliste steht ist positiv wer
vor acht jahren 2012 auf dem mars
gelandet war
doch noch immer ist er auf dem roten
planeten unterwegs und das obwohl die
mission ursprünglich nur auf zwei jahre
angelegt war
er sucht hier nach spuren vom früheren
leben und damit nach daten die einen
exorbitant wichtigen wert für
forschungsteams weltweit haben erst
anfang des jahres 2020 gelang ihm ein
wahnsinniger rekord der mars rover
curiosity hat das bislang größte bild
des roten planeten überhaupt geliefert
es besteht aus mehr als 1000
einzelbildern hat 1,8 milliarden pixel
es handelt sich um eine 360 grad
panoramaaufnahmen zu
anderen gelang heuer sind die ebenfalls
im jahr 2018 eine spektakuläre
entdeckung und zwar im jahr milliarden
altem gestein des mars hier spürte er
organischer materie auf die rede ist von
sehr einfachen kohlenstoffverbindungen
die hinweise auf eine lebensfreundliche
zeit auf dem roten planeten geben
konkret handelt es sich bei der
entdeckung um aromatische khalifa tische
und telefonische verbindung
möglicherweise hat es auf dem mars also
1 von mikroben nur so gewimmelt zudem
hatte der nasa rover auch eine
methankonzentration in der mars luft
festgestellt die stark schwankt auf der
erde entsteht methan durch biologische
prozesse beispielsweise wenn rinder ihre
nahrung verdauen also ein hinweis auf
leben auf dem mars der stationärer nasa
länder inside schafft es dann 2018 auf
den roten planeten
diese mission soll neue erkenntnisse zur
atmosphäre und zur geologie des mars
liefern im april des vergangenen jahres
2009 10 hatte das seismometer der nasa
mars sonde inside eine faszinierende
aufnahmen gemacht bei dem zittern wie
das forschungsteam ist bezeichnet hatte
handelte sich tatsächlich um ein
nachbeben auf dem roten planeten ein
paar mehrere denn niemals zuvor konnte
seismische aktivität auf dem maß
gemessen werden laut nasa eine
historische messung und somit ein
spektakulärer erfolg mit hilfe vom
instrument sei es sind die fachleute
also in der lage ins innere des roten
planeten reinzuhören quasi sowie
ärztinnen und ärzte mit ihrem stethoskop
in den menschlichen körper horchen
können dazu der insight experte bruce
banner
wir haben bisher hintergrundgeräusche
gesammelt doch dieses ereignis markiert
offiziell den beginn eines neuen
forschungsfeldes der erdbeben kunde das
maß erdbeben kunde hier im sinne von
erde grund und nicht im sinne des wortes
des planeten
der deutsche beitrag zu dieser mission
allerdings steckt im wahrsten sinne des
wortes in die schwierigkeiten gemeint
ist die sonde hp 3 mit dem spitznamen
maulwurf die vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt entworfen wurde der
plan sah vor dass sich die sonne in den
boden ein gräbt und von dort aus daten
über den kern des roten planeten zu
liefern doch das material an der mars
oberfläche stellte sich als klebrige und
zement artige roßkamp heraus und der
sonne gelang es nicht sich selbst
in den boden zu rammen stattdessen
prallte sie immer wieder ab und
schraubte sich so wieder aus der masse
heraus in den kommenden wochen wollen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler beraten wie die mission
des maulwurfs weitergehen soll in sieben
monaten also im februar 2021 heißt es
dann also daumen drücken denn die
landung auf dem mars ist nicht ohne die
usa sind die einzige nation denen
mehrere weiche landung auf dem mars
gelungen sind als herausforderung gilt
hier die hohe geschwindigkeit mit der
die raumfahrzeuge beim mars ein treffen
zum anderen ist die atmosphäre des roten
planeten sehr dünn so muss man eintritt
ein bestimmter winkel eingehalten werden
denn sonst sind die mechanischen und
thermischen belastungen zu stark und das
risiko besteht dass die lande einheiten
vergnügen ist der eintrittswinkel
dagegen zu flach kann der landeort
verfehlt werden oder die raumschiffe
sogar wieder in den weltraum zurück
geschleudert werden auch lokale
bedingungen am landeort wie etwa die
windgeschwindigkeit und die atmosphäre
ndigte machen die landung auf dem mars
zu einer echten herausforderung dennoch
der mars steht hoch im kurs und das ist
nicht nur bei der nasa der fall das hat
das laufende jahr 2020 noch einmal
eindrucksvoll gezeigt denn mit persil
wehrens sind im jahr 2020 bereits drei
raketen zum roten planeten aufgebrochen
in der vergangenen woche war die
raumsonde al amal der vereinigten
arabischen emirate gestartet an bord des
raumschiffes ist eine sonde die beim
umkreisen des mars seine atmosphäre
genauer ins visier nehmen soll
auch das chinesische raumschiff dann
wenn eins war in diesem monat gestartet
und hat ebenfalls einen rover an bord
hierbei handelt es sich um den zweiten
versuch chinas eine sonde zum mars zu
bringen dann wenn eins soll aus einer
mars umlaufbahn nach vorkommen von
wasser suchen die gesteine auf der
marsoberfläche kartieren und das
magnetfeld des roten planeten vermessen
das genau jetzt innerhalb kürzester zeit
drei flüge zum mars gestartet sind hat
einen einfachen grund denn derzeit
stehenden der rote planet und die erde
so günstig dass ein flug nur sieben
monate dauert und der energieaufwand
möglichst gering ist das ist nur alle
drei jahre der fall leben auf dem mars
schon längst entdeckt sehr spannendes
video von tim von astro comics also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran